what else we got i mean can you clear up
the modernity thing because you're
pretty good with like pharmaceutical uh
uh insider trading stuff
so the headline was modernist ceo dumps
1.5 million shares of moderna steps et
cetera et cetera that's what the
headline was
i don't think it was the ceo that dumped
the uh it was one of the co-founders
that dumped a big amount and i think the
ceo has been selling thousands of shares
but i think they kind of do that right i
think what this is this is none of this
is actually confirmed and it should be
able to confirm because i think all
sales are public record especially if
you're part of the company
but um here's the thing we know it's
over
so if you're a pharmaceutical company
you are making crazy bread you know that
your stock is going to go down not to
mention it looks like the stock market
is kind of ready to take a little dip
scale it's [ __ ] time bro right let's
get in yeah so um
i think i think again none of this is
completely confirmed or maybe it has
been since but um
i'm not surprised that this is happening
i'm not surprised this is happening yo
yo yo yo should you be allowed to sell
your shares if you are the ceo while you
are the ceo you have to hold on to them
shits until you quit right
that's an interesting one i think you
did step down uh
that would make sense you quit you cash
out
but anybody else involved in the company
after a certain level even maybe if
you're a lower level employee you
shouldn't be allowed to sell your shares
until you quit now do you think he's
looking at this and being like y'all are
criticizing me i saved your grandparents
you [ __ ] loser
like i saved y'all like you think that
these guys have a god complex right now
they're like hold on i saved millions of
people they upset it like a little
billion dollars that i came off yeah are
you kidding you should have paid me
30 billion for your whole family being
alive how much would you pay for your
grandma yeah probably right so i think
in his mind he's like of course i could
sell my stock i just saved the world
where we're looking like oh
you're trying to get over on us no but
he might be grateful he might be right
he might have a point he does have a
point man he saved the world i
understand that these vaccines don't
work yes and it could probably cause
tons of illnesses allegedly allegedly
don't take us off spotify but in all
seriousness it allowed us to go back
outside just the peace of mind of having
a vaccine whether real or not or
whatever it allows us to hey let's open
up the world again so they're seeing
themselves as heroes they're like of
course i'm going to sell my stock i
deserve it i worked hard i saved the
world
i created this placebo vaccine open up
the whole world
yeah 100
so i understand where that's coming from
yeah
and i'll be honest with you
i do empathize with him no i think
you're right i do empathize with him a
little bit he should be able to if he
wants to step down he's like okay i got
us through the [ __ ] cove but it's
over you don't really need me no more i
got us through i saved all these [ __ ]
people i had the most fire vaccine the
only vaccine they didn't have any
criticism yeah that was actually johnson
criticized pfizer criticized moderna
madonna killing it killing it strong so
can he not get breaded up real quick who
is actually mad who's actually who mad
at him me before we start talking about
this because i'm just saying like
sometimes i argue with me
sometimes i have an opinion so i start
talking about it and then i flip on that
[ __ ] yeah yeah and i'm angry that i
thought that [ __ ] before
yeah [ __ ] you
not all of you not new you oh yeah
dumbass yeah dumbass yeah [ __ ] me [ __ ]
me dude
stupid idiot yeah what about shitty you
should we talk about that before
dude yeah the haircut dude you look
[ __ ] familiar
dude before the haircut we got to talk
about you before the haircut man you
don't glowed up my boy thanks dog
thanks rick
um mark what are your thoughts on it
well it was like conspiracy and
right-wing twitter was being like oh
this is about to be the disclosure like
he's getting out before the whole thing
tanks because we're going to find out
the vaccine's giving people aids and
[ __ ] oh wow
oh wow which is still on that one it
could happen i got that one you got the
hiv no i got the modern one oh okay yeah
yeah yeah you might have it yeah yeah
yeah you might have fallen oh yeah but
who cares if you get aids aids curable
now that's good not curable
livable no no no no they came out with
some new shirts somebody's been
completely cured of aids recently you
can be cured of ace now you can how's
that not even news shut up we worried
about coleman now kobe doesn't even hate
his timeline
his aides now aids old news
he's like malaria now that [ __ ] we don't
got time for it god damn that was magic
is just like yeah just now finding out
about this [ __ ] bro new york times put
out the headline a woman is cured of hiv
using novel corona novel treatment
wow yeah so if you have hiv or you know
someone has hiv pipe it up
okay keep going though it seems like
some people can be out here [ __ ] it's
basically that thing that you were
saying is like their stock price was the
biggest in like august 2021
and has slowly like gone down since so
they're looking at it being like oh we
have all these shares the dude has like
3.4 billion in shares
and so basically he's like cooperating
with like securities and trade
commission being like oh i can sell this
amount in this period of time and he's
been selling off since like
you know june of 2020. yeah so he knew
if i want to cash in i want to make all
the money i got to do it in this time
period i can't do it all once or that's
going to tank the stock so i have to
look out for the company and the people
who are investing in it but i want to
make some money off the fact that i
saved millions of people that's probably
how he said this guy's a hero and this
is the highest it's going to be probably
he's like a canadian trucker this guy's
a hero he's he is a canadian he's the
canadian trucker of america why don't we
clap american ceos remember we was
clapping for these nurses doing tick
tocks all [ __ ] day while people died
in the goddamn hobstable
yeah they were all in the fixable room
you're like for real why don't we clap
for them truckers dude facts
i'm gonna clap for you right now [ __ ]
yeah
save saved you a lot of money saved you
a lot of money because of the shows in
toronto that are oh yeah hell yeah thank
you truckers
you know what i mean you got to bred
them up a little fine
i have one ticket
i'm giving away one ticket to a trucker
you gotta fight all the truckers of the
show i got it that'd be fire that would
be yeah yeah say it say it i got it and
i say it i would that would be not dude
all of them two truckers
you're more than welcome at the show
what kind of truck second what kind of
truck
they have to have a ton of truck okay
now that they absolutely have to have an
18 wheeler
oh yeah you can't come here with a
little nine-wheeler yeah yeah [ __ ] out
of here with your van oh you're your
mercedes mattress uh-uh go drive via
optimus prime yeah bro that's what i
need to say hell yeah pull up then
we got you two tickets four tickets whoa
we're gonna give away four tickets total
one per show
shows okay four tickets okay
i got four tickets do i hear eight
tickets eight tickets eight tickets
right
tickets
we're giving away
you better keep moving on my buddy okay
can we talk about it the one legged guy
too
terry yeah yeah he passed away the one
that died i mean just have an empty
chair for him out of respect in memoriam
you have to do canadian boom nine
hundred percent nine ticket let's go
one for that absolutely
you